Everything is science.
So there’s not anything you can touch or
see or do that has nothing to do with science.
Many students can tell you that I get really
carried away sometimes.
I get so carried away and so excited about
what I’m teaching.
Yeah, actually so that’s nine.
And I think that’s infectious for them as
well and it makes them really excited and
want to learn.
I tell them right away, “You will struggle
in this class.”
And that’s okay.
I struggled in class, in different classes,
along the way.
And that’s the only way that we’re going
to learn something.
The science classes that I taught, probably
in my first 10 years, students were not very
active in doing science.
There was very little ability for students
to fail at any of the activities we did.
So I had this conception when I started teaching
that in 10 years I was going to be a master
teacher.
It took me really up until this year to recognize
that perfection is a myth.
What scientific concept are we looking at
Mylani?
Friction.
What’s friction?
Without that initial engagement or really
enjoyment of learning, they’re not going
to want to pursue science at later ages.
I hope that they look at the world in a different
way and see science.
Also guys.
Gloves.
Glove up.
The opportunities of science come from the
unexpected that come through, which include
non-results.
Because the process of science is fraught
with running protocols and not having them
work but then having interesting questions
that arise from that process.
It’s not just about a struggle problem.
It’s about struggling and getting through
and learning through your actual struggle,
like persevering.
I want them to be able to stand on their own
two feet and prove to somebody else whether
in school or in life why something is correct
or why something makes sense to them.
With a little bit more time to explore other
dimensions of physics, I can construct these
units and these projects that are more authentic.
And so they see what they could do if they
were to pursue an engineering career or pursue
something in computer science, as opposed
to just pure applied physics.
Regardless of whether we’ve been teaching
five, 10, 20 years, there’s always some
other way that we can grow and develop.
Something else that we can learn and potentially
share with our students.